Some of y'all can't think for yourself and it shows.
The Ballerina Farms article that came out,
the internet is just running with it.
Riddle me this.
How do we go from hating somebody because they're cosplaying,
being poor cause they're doing home making and home sitting activities,
to then hating her because she must have nanny,
she's unrealistic,
to now feeling pity for her for an article that came out
that most likely isn't accurate and has a lot of bias?
And why this article? Well,
because culture hates women
who feel fulfilled by being a wife and a mother.
Anytime you go against what is countercultural
to the main narrative of what a woman should be
according to feminism, you're an enemy.
A woman should pursue her career no matter who it hurts,
no matter what it takes. She should be selfish.
She should think of herself first.
Emma is incredibly successful.
She is a businesswoman.
She has managed her household on top of being a businesswoman.
She has eight children. Successful.
That's successful. And because she didn't pursue Juilliard,
that now she's oppressed.
Women can change their minds and what they want in life.
I know because I did it.
I used to want a very lucrative medical based career.
I wanted to be working non stop.
And then I met my husband.
And after I met my husband,
my priorities in life changed,
my goals changed in life. Something that I didn't see changing,
but that's What happens in life?
Things change. That doesn't mean you're oppressed.
That doesn't mean you're being held back by your spouse.
Only people who know how Hannah and Daniel's marriage works
is Hannah and Daniel.
And to insert yourself into something and think you know everything
based on one sleazy journalist article is embarrassing to yourself.
So get a hobby, mind your own business, and move on.